Speaker 1: This video is it's an SNL skit,
except it's actually not. As many of you know,
there has been this Canadian trucker convoy and
it has been infected by, but also, to some degree,
organized by a radical extremist fringe. The
big picture of what's going on in Canada. And we
interviewed Lance from the serfs on a live stream
earlier this week about it. 90. This is, according
to Lance. Ninety percent of Canadian truckers are
vaccinated, but there is some. I guess in theory,
some of that 90 percent, but really mostly
from the 10 percent that is unvaccinated,
they want to end vaccine mandates. Now
a reasonable question would be well.
Which mandates because there's there are
provincial vaccine mandates in Canada, in many,
many provinces, but also to truck to the United
States. The U.S. requires proof of vaccination.
Even if you get your province to say you don't
need to be vaccinated to do your trucking to the
U.S., you'd still need to be vaccinated, just one
of the many questions here. And one of the things
about it is that obviously not all the truckers
who don't want the mandates are racist. Obviously,
obviously, obviously. But some of the organizers
have a history of white nationalism and racism.
We heard from the Canadian Anti-Hate Network
who says we are calling this a far right convoy
because from day one, the organizers
themselves are part of the far right.
They've been previously involved in far right
movements. They've made Islamophobic comments
in the past, et cetera, et cetera. So this is,
I mean, you, you can't script this any better.
Jesse Waters, newly minted as the host of
I think, maybe the seven o'clock hour Jesse
Waters now has a show daily on Fox. He wanted
to prove how not racist the truckers are.
So he finds a freedom convoy trucker named
Sobha Veasey and brings him on to prove how
not racist the truckers are. And the trucker
says, I'm not racist. I have colored friends.
Guys, it's it's it's it's beyond parody. Take
a look at this. It sounds like like an SNL skit
Speaker 2: that was only one guy saw. You
are not racist. I have all types of friends.
Call our friends, Spanish, Chinese, you know, they
are great people. There is no racism here, guys.
Speaker 1: I don't know if he has colored
friends. How racist could he really be?
It's it's beyond parody now. To be fair, he
clearly speaks English as a second language.
So the use of the word colored could be a language
issue. But the optics are absurd. And that being
said, even if the use of the word colored comes
from English being a second language. The concept
of I'm not racist because I have black friends
at this point could not possibly be more cliche.
So Jesse Waters looking to prove how not racist
the truckers are? And coming up with this bizarre,
bizarre appearance that could just as easily
have been from Saturday Night Live or Mad TV,
the truckers are still going. They're still
going in Canada. They're honking horns and
doing doing other things. And my expectation is
that probably in the next week or so, it'll all
start to wind down. I don't believe
they are going to have any success in
eliminating the vaccine mandates. That's my
sense. As of right now, if you expect them to
have any achievements as far as that
goes, let me know I want to hear from you.